today we are going to see a very
exciting game a very interesting
attacking game where I see I'm sure
you'll see some familiar motifs but also
some orchids that maybe you're not so
familiar with and also like I said
behind the scenes there are some
exciting moves because the player who
won a brilliancy still didn't play the
absolute best moves
maybe we can improve a little bit and
then we are going to have for dessert a
little combination that's one of my
favorites and we'll see how you'll do
with that so without further ado we're
gonna go with the game the game is
played by two players that I must say
that I've never heard before
okay probably there are masters I think
Austrian masters or something like that
so e4 that's familiar to us all b5 and
now he plays the move Knight c3 how many
of you have played this or faced it with
white or black some of you
okay so Knight to f6 and who could tell
me of those of you play it probably is
gonna be easier if you haven't played
before might be harder what is one of
the main moves here of course it's not
too late for white to change his mind
play Knight f3 just like in the spirit
of the four Knights maybe black will
answer with knight c6 will have a four
Knights game that's normal I can play
the very exciting move Bishop to c4
which is actually allowing your center
fork trick but we will talk about in one
second but who could tell me what is the
main move here what is the principal
move of the Vienna defense 93 nine f6 is
known as the Vienna and who could tell
me what is the principal move of the
Vienna any ideas you you're a lot to
raise your hand and guess I haven't hurt
anybody that I guessed wrong yet in my
life so yes well I mean I don't know if
I'm crazy about leaving my bishop in
already without making some sort of a
commitment yes
say again I think that pd4 here doesn't
make sense because after pawn takes
Queen takes Knight c6 I'm immediately
attacking the Queen right and otherwise
you can't play the usual gambit well the
movies f4 the moving the move played in
the game is f4 and that's the main
excitement of the Vienna by the way I
want to discuss this variation I wasn't
really planning on it but I think that
it's a good idea to talk a little bit
about this variation this is a kind of a
variation that could be exciting I'm
just gonna mention it for a moment
because it's really good to know and the
idea is that of course black plays the
move 94 that's the main move
if you don't play this move then it's
just gonna be some sort of an Italian
game if you play 96 I can play Knight f3
but I also have the options of always
playing f4 and my Bishop is already on a
very aggressive diagonal so usually
black wants to play the move Knight
takes e4 now some of you might say what
the knight is protected
protecting the square but this is known
as the Center for trick if white now
takes here which is a very bad move then
after d5 and I'm regaining the piece and
at best you can get your pawn back but
I'm gonna be the one who's happier I'm
gonna have either a pawn in the center
here or a pawn in the center here much
easier development this Bishop is buried
in and of course this is great for
Black's point of view let's say you play
something like I don't know Bishop here
I take take Bishop d6 of course I'd
rather be black than white in this
position there's no question about it
I'm going to play f5 and kick that
Bishop I can Castle early and White is
still behind development it's like white
is playing black and black is playing
white not a very wise idea so you might
say wait a minute didn't you recommend
Bishop c4 as an option the answer is yes
but the follow-up is anybody wants to
think why is white giving the pawn what
move or idea might be have in mind yes
almost say same kind of idea of
aggression oops I did not play that move
yet Queen h5 a very good aggressive move
that's the idea of this gambit now the
threat of mate and the threat on the
knight force block to play the next move
because if he doesn't play the next move
something very bad is going to happen if
you try to first of all I'm attacking
the pawn so you can play g6 Queen takes
pawn here is going to win the world if
you play Queen e7 then I can take your
knight and there's no d5 because
nobody's protecting d5 so the only move
who could tell me the only defensive
move in this position if you don't play
this move you're going to lose as black
so for better or for worse you have only
one defensive move use your imagination
you Knight is being hit and you're about
to get mated that's not fun I'm seeing
only the same two hands and I bet that I
can see more I don't mind I don't mind
if you don't know it's okay not to know
but I want you to try to consider it the
question is very easy think about it
this is more it's not even a chess
question it's a logic question I'm
threatening checkmate
I am also threatening your knight and
now yeah you know the question you
already don't know the question I get
out okay so let's hear from yes Queen g5
is not very recommended think about it
I'm going to do Queen takes f7 and my
knight is attacking here here and
painful right yeah how do we save the
night and stop the mate come on this is
such an easy question it's the second
door on the right
okay okay let's hear from you yes yellow
shirt yeah you have to play 96 the night
is saving itself preventing the mate and
attacking the bishop and in this
position it's kind of known that if the
Queen rushes to take this pawn the
bishop grows to e7
yeah sure white Regained is born but at
the same token black is developing
quickly is going to cancel and for now
the white king and queen are kind of
lined up on the same diagonal so
normally white plays the move Bishop to
b3 and now he wants to play the move
that often zap often happens Knight to
b5 to distract this Knight and trying to
somehow mate okay this is not a topic
for today I just mentioned it as a
sideline as an aside option it's a
sideline for our game
so in our game as we said f4 was played
and we didn't know about that now we
learned that that move is possible this
is a super aggressive move kind of in
the spirit of the Kings gambit but
notice that the addition of the Knights
being out is maybe limiting blacks
choices a little bit it's not so easy to
play etext f4 for example because then
the question is is the knight really
great here because there's an e5 ideas
and d4 in the center is very good so
what do you think is a good idea for
black here again especially since no one
really knows this opening so you have to
rely on your intuition what would be a
good move when there is like I can give
a little hint it often happens when
somebody attacks you from the flank what
do you like to do when somebody attacks
you from the side what is almost always
a good response or a normal response yes
um even better than that even better
because if you just defend and your
opponent has more space of forces then
it's gonna be a very yeah yes sorry
counter-attack Howell that's right can't
you're attacking the center so this is a
very good exciting move black wants to
again open up his game attack the center
open up his bishops and okay the normal
move for white of course is to take on
e5 which is not protected and the knight
is now under attack the pawn on d5 is
under attack black responds with a very
logical Knight takes before very nice so
both sides have achieved something the
knight is very active on e4 very
annoying from why it's going to view and
this one is very beautiful for white
takes away some important squares you
will see later that it can play a great
part now there are several main lines
that unknown again notice that this game
is not exactly a new game only a hundred
and fifteen years old but still it's
very exciting because of what happened
in it now we know that there's a move d3
crazy line pawn goes to d3 and in the
case of Queen h4 check g3 the knight can
take that pawn and of course you cannot
take back and there's lots of threads so
Knight the f3 this is a crazy crazy
variation Queen h5 regime are all kinds
of stuff okay again not a topic for
today but just you know that it exists
in our game where I decided to play
something a lot more normal he decided
to play Knight to f3 he doesn't like to
deal with all those annoying checks and
he prefers that to happen not to happen
so he plays Knight I have three stopping
the checks developing the knight but of
course the knight here is in no rush so
that means that blacks next move which
was Knight takes c3 may have been a
little too early what is the rush to
take you weren't attack
why are you crying before you're hurt
right so other moves it would have been
normal one is to play Bishop g4 develop
the bishop the other one is to develop
this Bishop so you can cancel quickly I
think when I put it in the computer they
suggested the move Bishop c5 which is
kind of interesting maybe he
wants to get white to play d4 so he can
pin the night here on c3 okay I didn't
think that that was so amazing but who
can argue with comodo so black played
like I said Knight takes c3 now how
should we take back be pond or D pond
and why I want to hear both arguments
and then I'm going to show you what was
played Adie
with the be pond explain the logic okay
very good
anybody thinks otherwise anybody
disagrees everybody want to take with
the D pawn yeah this is a very big
dilemma and it's normally in almost
every opening we want to take toward the
center in e4 e5 openings you'll notice
that most of the time like in the
exchange Roy Lopez and in like many four
nights variations somehow the deep one
ends up taking because it opened up the
Queen and open up the opens up the
bishop on c1 so it seemed like both are
possible but in our game indeed Rd is
right he took it over the center for it
exactly the reason is he mentioned he
wants to use the rook on the B file very
important and he wants to play the move
d4 gaining space in the center also very
very important okay excellent
so now black played the move Bishop e7
okay another move that I think is very
nice is to play c5 and quickly knight c6
because you immediately put pressure in
the center and sometimes you have a
chance to play the move Queen a5 early
before white already developed and
counseled and create some pressure so I
think that if I was black in this
position which I hope I wouldn't because
I would never take him on c3 so early
but still I would have played the move
c5 and with the intention of 96 Queen a5
leave that Bishop here just one more
move so Bishop e7 pond e4 again I'm
voting for c5 black castle Bishop to d3
all this is very good and logical I
think it makes sense why develops in a
very attacking Stan
black realizes that sooner or later he
has to Castle kingside so he does now
comes the move Bishop to g4 okay not a
mistake by itself but again the main
plan has to be playing c5 that would be
a lot more urgent get your counter play
and get it now see what white is gonna
do is white going to take out c5 and
break his pawn structure forever and we
can this diagonal forever not not gonna
be easy for White Castle
or is he going to allow black to take
and then maybe go Queen a5 jack is he
going to allow maybe c4 kicking the
bishop from this very important diagonal
that's a lot more challenging so in the
game here on Bishop g4 and who could
tell me why am I not crazy about this
move it's not a blunder it's not like oh
my god here is the punishment no but
there is an immediate reason where I
don't I'm not really caring for this
move so much and it's a positional
reason let's see if somebody can tell me
yes that's right
immediately the palm of b7 means
babysitting and if I was about to play
rook be one anyways now I'm playing it
with a big game of temper
why allowed the tempo no not urgent
could have played like I said c5 96 and
then if you ever play brook b1 then one
would ask is rook b1 really the best
timing for that shouldn't you play for
it later because now black is causing
some trouble on the Queen side and
center so after here indeed rook to b1
maybe black should have just pitched
that porn on b7 just played c5 would
have been interesting but who can blame
him for not wanting to sac upon when
he's not even that up in development how
did you want to add something yeah he
played the move b6 he decided not to
give up this pawn and he defends it with
b6 okay so I plays castles again a move
that doesn't deserve doesn't need that
many explanations and black played the
move c5 the commentator said that the
move f6 was very interesting because of
the situation tried to hit in the center
try to provoke one of two things either
to force white you take and then the
bishop takes or to try to take yourself
on e5 and maybe isolate this pawn and
open the F file later on for some action
but I still think that white is better
in that position after f6 so c5 now what
to do what moves or what move or moves
do you have in mind I think that white
played the most concrete move in this
position I think he played the most
accurate take a moment look at the
position pretend that you white there
are several moves that make sense here
and I can't say that they are blunders
but I think that right here right now
before black starts exercising his many
other options it's time to do something
let's see if you guys are with me on
that take a moment look at the position
think what should white you
okay let's pretend it's your own game
and you have to make a move what would
you make here what move would you play
I don't think anybody is thinking I move
like let's say Ruby - right that doesn't
make any sense right everybody's
laughing of course so let's try to think
of moves that make sense yes Bishop III
seems like a reasonable move developing
the last undeveloped minor piece and
making sure that it has an extra eye in
the center ok reasonable anybody else
yes
Bishop III interesting you want to kind
of check the other diagonal out and my
only problem with that is that maybe at
the right time there's gonna be like a
c4 move and black isn't gonna be said
about trading pieces and selling that
Bishop out keeping the white double
pawns in fact so well let me play the
move h3 immediately asking the bishop
the question before c4 might be coming
and white would have to declare what he
wants this Bishop to be probably is to
go back to Egypt we asked the bishop
dude what are you going to do are you a
giving yourself up for the night
giving me a lot of light squares making
me really happy about that and a pair of
bishops are you're going to try to
maintain the pin or are you going to
just quietly withdraw back on that
diagonal you came from now what would
you do if you're black you have three
decisions right like I said trade
retreat from where you came from or
maintain the pen which one of the three
would you want to choose I wanna I want
everybody to participate at the end of
these questions I want everybody to have
a vote of what they want to do so we'll
take a vote right now how many of you
want to trade the bishop for the knight
zero votes how many of you want to go
back let's say Bishop to e6 one person
how many of you want to play the move
Bishop to h5 maintain the pin one two
three four five six seven well let's see
what black did bishop h5 now everybody's
good and happy right okay now what
should we do it white continue our plan
what do you think we should do
you're white in this position what move
our moves should be your candidate moves
if you want to suggest Bishop III or
Bishop f4 okay we already said that
Bishop coming to the center helping out
a little bit like before let's hear from
you
g4 so you want to kick up the bishop you
want to break that pin once and for all
right and you want to maybe after Bishop
g6 maybe you want to trade okay that's
one plan what else what other ideas
might we have in mind yes Queen e1 yes
okay you want to break the pin once and
for all and you want to do Queen e1 g3
maybe bring the Queen to an active spot
or maybe Queen d2 to f4 that was your
idea I'm assuming yeah very reasonable
very reasonable well the reason why I'm
asking it in that kind of sneaky way is
because I'm trying to check your alert
level your danger level that's why
before I made no comment on the move
Bishop h5 and now I'm just I didn't say
why to move in when a white to move
here's an exciting possibility I just
kept on going with the game as if you're
just a regular game and just to see if
one of you has like a red light or
anything blinking saying wow I'm sensing
that there's something in this position
but you guys just went with me and
nothing really happened so I have to
make a comment in this position
Bishop h5 is a blunder it looks like a
great move and it's good at you guys
many of you suggested it because hey it
looks like a trivial move it looks like
the most logical move you attack my
Bishop I don't feel like giving it for
the night I don't really want to move it
backwards I don't want to move it
backwards I want to maintain the pin I
love the pin and when I'm looking at the
position it's like everything is super
protected some of you might say yeah but
what about this Bishop sacrifice and
then I check and I might say yeah but
there's a bishop here and there's a
queen here right usually what the bishop
is not an e7 we suck the bishop and life
is great however here things are
different but as much as they're
different they're also a little bit the
same and the problem is
white played drumroll Bishop ate salmon
anyway he sacrificed and now black is
really in trouble until now he was doing
relatively okay if you were to even take
him the night or just retreated with the
bishop wouldn't be the end of the world
but as it is Bishop h5 Bishop takes a
salmon wins the game for white well I
don't have to tell you that if you have
to move your king and you have lost the
pawn so import such an important for
nine eight seven and I'm gonna have an
extra point plus the attack that's not
gonna be a great solution however taking
the bishop is also not a great solution
because now you will notice that the
attack plays itself even though there's
a bishop on a seven white still
continues in the normal typical Greek
sacrifice style Knight to g5 check and
some of you might look and say wait a
minute I see that on g5 we have one
defender on c1 I also see that we have
two attackers on e7 and d8 all that is
true but of course the queen is
attacking the bishop on h5 to boot which
is a big bonus now what should we do
let's check all the possibilities let's
pretend that I say oh if I give this
Bishop I'm gonna get in real trouble
for example if let's say we go here then
BAM threatening mate I'm pretty certain
that all of you see that this this is
going to be very miserable for black for
example if he goes rook e8 I'm going to
go check and yeah looks a lot like mate
so after excuse me oopsie after here
here Bishop takes Bishop takes and let's
say I move my queen away now my idea is
if you're going to go rook up I want to
play the move f5
so if we had this position what do you
think white had in mind what move about
listen I don't only hear the first move
I want to hear some sort of a plan I
want to hear some sort of an idea it's
like I want to go here if you do this
I'll do that my threat is X Y Z I'm
pretty certain that if you took a strong
master or Grand Master and you asked him
okay what would you do here I would sit
within three four or five seconds not be
an idea because a they have seen it
before be they could just sense that
with all the black pieces doing nothing
you think these two guys are helping
somewhere from the bleachers up top and
the nosebleeds yeah they're not helping
so yes okay maybe I'm not doubting it it
probably Brooke f6 is a decent move I
don't think it can be taken because pawn
takes Bishop takes on Quidditch mate h8
maples good and the meantime you're
gonna double rooks and maybe bring the
rook to a time sure it's also
interesting but he planned to play the
very simple Bishop f6 because between a
bishop and a pawn that's enough and this
is just the end of the world I'm
threatening Queen g5 and made here or
Queen h6 making the vow squares I'm
threatening rook up I'm threatening to
take on g7 and I just it's just a
complete disaster okay so that's out not
a lovely variation right so what if we
do something else what if we play King
up now I'm just saying okay I'm holding
on to my bishop you cannot take my
bishop now if Queen takes bishop it's a
beautiful sacrifice but there's no mate
I'm gonna take with my King g4 King g6
and that's the end of that but in this
position we have a very simple solution
come on white to move how do we mate
there is no way that I'm going to be
happy to see just one hand up just use
your imagination
the black King looks like a travelling
clown we have to punish it I'm seeing
the same three or four hands guys don't
be shy look at the position have guts
think yourself the
King is in trouble he has no legal moves
he can only go to 86 but when he goes to
86 he goes right into the discovery of
the bishop and my knife is gonna go wild
knight of seven so so the kid in the
black shirt yes Queen d3 check BAM
disaster and of the world what to do
what am I gonna go say that I decide to
go f5
blocking the church yay am I am I really
blocking the check how do you unblock
the check easily somebody say it yeah
yes that doesn't look good that does not
look good because King a chick is gonna
lead to the same thing so if I go King
here what's the best move I want the
best move I'm a greedy greedy guy I have
so many hot moves here only one gets the
nod only one gets the yes all the others
no keeper the glasses also go also good
because it's double check and mate okay
who can find another check making one
move get out of class yes that also
looks like checkmate everything one fact
check me you can already see that this
is just such a disaster goodness
so you have another thing to add I
mentioned it
while you were sleeping I said double
check and mate we're late 7f 7 you mean
Knight X we're okay after I go let's say
here then what do you play well I mean
Knight takes here is mated Queen texia
Queen here is made you can go 96 which
I'm pretty sure it's not gonna lose the
game however it's not the best we always
look for the best okay so forget about
this variation this is not fun either
so he decided to just take it well the
next move is easy
we took here track and now we already
know from the previous example that if
the King goes to g8 okay Bishop takes g5
and then Bishop f6 with an immediate
disaster so he is gonna try to play here
now he's protecting his extra piece yay
but again we look at the position we see
the King a little bit by himself all the
other black pieces are in the last rank
not helping we already called how do we
call these two spectators somewhere in
the nosebleeds right of the bleachers
not helping and we have lots of pieces
aiming at the attack the Queen is
maximum capacity we have a bishop here
participating and rook here
participating all these are great what
moves do we have here I think that the
move that he played was not the best
move but versus good enough to win so
let's see if you can find what I think
is the best move but either move gets
the point so but I'm only seeing one kid
raising their hand as if this is the the
meaning of life kind of question come on
this is not that hard
howdy tell me that what was played and
it was very good it gets the point like
I said Bishop takes 86 you'll see how it
continued but anybody else would like an
exciting move yes that's the letter R
Graham has to say it yeah Rock f6 is
definitely the best move
rook f6 is just very very annoying
because if pawn takes we have Queen
takes bishop followed by pawn takes here
not good you can say key Queen also
doesn't help because just the position
collapses immediately collapses so in
the game he played here and the reason
is this does
the best the best not because g6 is
possible he doesn't have to take back is
he lost
oh yeah sure he's lost he's dead loss
but again we are looking for the
absolute best shortest way to victory so
we cannot not mess up anything anyways
he decided to just take back after which
I want to see the whole class raising
their hand and telling me what it won't
play can the Queen mate by itself answer
now we need reserves what do we what do
we have how many you think that White's
plan here was King H 2 G 3G 4 F 5 and
etc how many you vote for that you out
so use your imagination what piece can
he use and where are we going to put it
in the most impressive square that is
not a tough question like for example
let's let's try this rock
we're not going to do with it where am I
going to climb up this way am I gonna
move here it's gonna take me a year now
I probably can do better than that rock
that's not doing anything so come on
imagination yes you could do that I
won't be surprised if this also wins
because black is so behind development
that by the time after rook F 7 he will
trade I'll check you then my other rock
will come into the game I'm positive
it's winning but again I'm a very tough
customer I insist on the shortest
fastest route yes
rook f6 once again misery for black of
course in this position if you would
have taken the rock he would have
prolonged the fight a little bit but he
didn't want to do it he just wanted to
move away after which of course White
has a very easy mate in three moves he
did ma'am bam and bam closing the deal
and when you look at the two positions
the black King say again
yes especially b8 and AAA they never
moved and when you look at the two kings
the black king is shouting help in every
language known to men the white king is
sitting pretty on g1 never touched never
in danger just a beautiful attacking
game my wife and amazing that sometimes
it only takes one little mistake in this
position he was not doing so badly it's
only this move that all of a sudden
brought something that you should be
familiar with well it's a Rufus vs.
doofus so in this position as you can
see block is doing okay but one little
mistake and again I on purpose
went it over this game I didn't say
anything about Bishop h5 and then I said
okay what should white play here and you
guys suggest that all kinds of Bishop
moves or because again it looks like an
innocent position but with very hidden
possibility that when we exercise it
ended in a disaster great now we're
gonna have one more time before you get
to get some free play one more position
okay this is one of them Alexander are
you keen or Alec honest is sometimes
called one of his best combinations if
you've seen it before which you might
have because this appears I'm sure in
books in magazines maybe in exercises I
mean I've seen it in more than one
source but I think it's one of the most
beautiful combination that I've seen I
don't know if it was played blindfold or
not it might have been play blindfold if
you raise your hand so soon that means
you've seen it so hands down please
that's everybody that's right let's be
fair about it I want everybody to have a
fair shot people that haven't seen it to
look at it and we can see that White has
a beautiful attack and this is a white
to move and win exercise okay of course
he's done a piece but the black King
looks a little unhappy the White King is
just vacationing the blocking is just
about to die there's like two rocks on
the file but we can already see that if
we go check King f7 maybe it's not the
prettiest King in the world and after g6
maybe the key is going to keep running
but there's no mate that's not happy
that is definitely not a happy idea so
we have to use our image
how do we get checkmate now of course
everybody says g6g six go G six because
you closed the meeting now but what if
my queen will just take it and then you
say yeah yeah Queen C four check Quincy
four check close the gate yeah but what
if I go D five and then everybody's like
uh-huh
so in other words we have to think a
little bit about this position how do we
get it right we already understand the
ideas we have a Quincy four check
sometimes we have a g6 sometimes both
movies are going to lock the Nathe met
the mate net on the king the king is
going to be trapped in a box gonna be
very hard to stop mate but we need to do
it smartly if we do it in a silly way
then there's always going to be an
escape question there's only one way to
do it properly I just said if you guys
know it don't raise your hand let people
that haven't seen it since know it only
if the everybody gives up are we going
to solve it I'm gonna let you saw it so
we're looking at this position we
understand everything is about the
checkmate everything is about the
weakness of the blocking but how do we
do it right just because we know the
idea doesn't mean that we're gonna win
the game we have to make it properly if
we don't do it the right way we're gonna
end up with nothing so I want everybody
to think use your imagination you takes
a lot of imagination here a lot of guts
and imagination to do it properly how do
we do it in the absolute proper way how
do you try Wow Queen takes g7 king takes
okay so let's say I go King to a g8
so we have check and I took you checked
me and my king went back if you check me
again I'm gonna go LA and LA zig zag
away run run run run right so again good
try but somehow my king is escaping my
king is a very mischievous guy huh yes
very good try let's try that out
Queen to c4 and what if I go away in a
minute
what if I go wow I don't know if I can
say I'm afraid to take it but maybe I
can take it let's try it I'll take it
then you're gonna go g6 right are you
ready now to give me checkmate if it's
your move you'll checkmate me right so I
have to do something about it
you have to otherwise I'll take your
rook for free and then I'm gonna play
Bishop here
oopsie the pontiff wants to give
checkmate is about to go bye-bye very
annoying right I know I know
so again now we understand all those
ideas g6 can do Queeny c4 can do so what
are we going to do let's try
oopsie let's try g6 Queen takes let's
try check
and now d5 Unknowing where did that d5
come from so what about my v5 you take
my queen I'm going to take your queen
and then oopsy I can suck my queen from
one of your works because when you take
I'll take your queen
no go so so annoying right very
difficult but what if I go g6 one more
time and then after Queen takes we're
gonna go 95 now now the idea is if you
take an e5
I'm gonna go Queen C for Chuck and when
you block the check on f7 rook h8 is
yeah unfortunately bam bam
no mate and black is still fighting
remember he started this a piece up so
if I give up a queen for a rock and a
piece I'm not doing too badly this is
becoming really really annoying we try
g6 failed
Quincy four failed maybe something else
tell us save us king f7
okay King takes
kingi six not yet also after rook check
King here yeah yeah I have to go I have
to take it yeah but no mate alright one
last chance yes do it tell me okay so we
go with the c4 I take it pawn to g6 I
have to set my queen back you must take
it only bigger move what are the 91 yeah
if you go 91 I'll just take your rook
because I'm already upper Queen now you
want to play this move as black because
you want to take that pawn and if you go
night h4 rook f6 that palm goes bye-bye
and there's no mate very very annoying
of course black is doing super well
right yeah well let me show you the
solution
oh one more person yeah tell me yay we
have a solution 95 this is exactly what
I often played beautiful little move
well he wants to play rook a checkmate
do something about it dude
I II have to if you don't take with a
pawn your other options to take with a
queen then of course after I trade
Queens and I go g6 how are you stopping
Rock h8 mate you cannot sorry okay so he
takes to the pawn okay we lost the night
and what not now even better than that
maybe you can take the pawn but if you
take with the pawn maybe I can go Queen
to g6 preventing g6
that's right that's right if Queen takes
e5 I take when you go g6 I have a little
check here and then I can just block
with my queen I don't carry follows my
queen for a walk after already taking
everything else right so yeah so what do
we do instead did we just lose a night
for nothing no we want to get them moved
g6 in how do we do it how do we do it
tell me no that's what we just said you
can do it because the Queen takes here
I'll show you if Queen takes Queen takes
then you go g6 then check you have to
respond to the check and then whoopsie
no mate and if you count the material I
already want you Queen for nothing so I
don't care if you take it for a rock
it's a good deal for me no no no can do
it so 95 D takes e5 and now yes alright
let's try it if you go Queen C for now
we can see it because it's not there
wait
if Queen C for here I'm gonna take it
then check row here
Bishop here no mate and I'm about to
take your stuff and my next move is
taking the pawn and that's it no mate
okay the final I'll show you what what
you guys missed that after pawn takes he
goes g6 surprised now you can take my
queen you get made it you can get made
it so you say well you gotta take now
that the D pawn move from blocking we
moved it here because of the night sac
we are going to go Queen c4 check what a
beautiful combination now you can play
Bishop d5 and I'll take it
sooner or later you're gonna have to
block on f7 either with a rock on the
Queen that takes away the last escape
from the king so after rook h8 is
correctamundo
so you want
yay now some free play